it's all about speed though and who can
adapt faster to this new time control
are you correct here we go it's king
spawn open the italian game just like
the previous couple of battles where
gary had white
and uh the main line so
both pieces just both sides just
bringing their pieces out controlling
the center
this rook move
very very logical stuff this is well
known territory this last pawn push for
black designed to put the black dark
square bishop back on a nice safe square
and what will gerry do will he move at
night will he push upon
lots of options good choice do you think
guys uh in terms of openings
uh guillory i think so you know because
it kind of keeps uh
you know maintains flexibility and one
thing we've seen is that this is a
common choice in this particular tie
breaks because all the pieces remain on
the board and the position is still
tense
still very very tense and it will be for
a long time
gary it feels like he hasn't quite
adjusted there's no real reason to think
for too long in a blitz game in this
position it's still a well-known
position there's still plenty of viable
choices for white
the problem with this opening the
italian game is sometimes too much
choice you can
kind of mix and match lots of lots of
different plans you just have to pick
one and stick with it
gary thinking for over 30 seconds
that feels like a rapid type of decision
not a blitz decision
save those 30 seconds for later he
hasn't frozen on the webcam no
okay it pushes a pawn gaining some space
and black does likewise losing a move
this pawn has now moved twice but this
is a well-known idea i think introduced
by alexander grisstruck
oh
and okay the white bishop now putting
some pressure on the black knight
i'm not going to try and explain some of
these moves because i don't understand
them frankly they're too deep and too
sophisticated
okay
well clocks are ticking this is blitz
chess pragnanda looking focused with the
black pieces a joy here is a good result
for him right
very good result despite losing with
white in the last game private lander
he's much more dangerous i think with
the white pieces
and uh okay the black bishop
retreating i'm expecting white tonight
the night sitting at home if you look at
all the white pieces on the left flank
they're still asleep i need to bring
them out
one of them has to develop
okay there we go gary spent a lot of
time up to this point though and no
trades yet no real critical moments
uh
have been reached
so what is there to calculate yeah
is that a calculating uh
face any issues having here looks
confused slightly
maybe just trying to get himself
motivate himself to speed up and there
we go gary speeding up the white knight
is destined to kind of sit in front of
its own king the two knights are going
to sit together
next door
and and the black knight presumably is
also going to make a journey okay it's
done that make a journey to the right
yeah afraid
yeah
to trade or not to trade guys what do
you think
um
trade no not trade no trade no trade
keep the bishops on the board bishop's
on the board okay he says you can
exchange you can trade off but on my
terms and gear is hoping that we see a
light square bishop exchange so that
white can take back with the pawn and
open up a line for his rook
and uh simon who would you prefer to be
in this position
it's very tense right yeah i think it's
pretty even um i mean normally is the
person with more experience in these
kind of positions because it's it's
going to be a maneuvering battle
so i i would say you know nisha's a lot
older uh generally i mean at least 10 20
years ago you say the guy with
experience but nowadays it's all
different than i don't know how many
games online prague's played in this
situation you could have played hundreds
of thousands already so it's really just
you know and anything can still happen i
think at the moment and uh expect some
long maneuvering before the position
opens up and one thing we could also
mention from gary is he said in a
previous interview in this tournament
he's changed his mouse technique um he's
no longer clicking and dragging he's
just clicking the squares because he had
several mouse lips last month in the
oslo esports cup and yeah a mouse slip
in a blitz game is
i mean the
likelihood goes up a lot in rapid chess
you can slowly kind of take your time
make the move you gain 10 seconds after
every turn but
blitz chess mouse lips happen all the
time that's right so he used to so he
used to click and then drag the piece
drag the piece yeah but sometimes i
think maybe it's on the chest 24 play
zone it's different from others um
sometimes something might go wrong
sometimes he's forgotten that he clicked
on a piece
like two minutes ago and then he drags
it and a different piece ends up on that
square
so he's definitely changed his technique
um if you click and click there's
nothing that can go wrong aha click and
click click and click and there we go
look at the knights symmetrical yeah
slow game so far but it must explode at
some time because clocks are ticking
really fast in blitz chess yeah this is
a very typical type of position okay
white is the first to break in the
center it's a very normal type of
position and it's cost both players a
lot of time especially prague
prague is the lower one on the clock now
one minute down
he needs to decide do you trade pawns in
the center of the board do you just
maintain the tension
there's no right or wrong here you just
need to move okay well there we have it
i probably would capture just because i
like trades yeah i mean it's looking i'd
say quite nice for a niche just because
of the extra time you know he's now over
a minute up he's got a minute 15 seconds
and that that that is important uh there
is increment but not as much if they get
under a minute it's going to be a lot
quicker
than even the rapid play so more
exchanges are occurring in the middle
here yeah so now white has an isolated
pawn in the center of the board and
we've talked about isolated pawns a lot
simon's highlighted some ideas uh over
the last few days white's isolated pawn
is a weakness long term
but black and and black has good squares
around that isolated pawn but white's
pieces are nice and active that is the
compensation and okay anish just slowly
improving his bishop you know this one
is still very much rapid chest speed
um we will see it become fast and
furious very shortly only 18 moves
played so far
they've done half their time haven't
they yeah so it's crazy yeah i mean that
if they go like this it'll be over by
move 40 because one of them will lose on
time so it's like they got to speed up
you know i mean it's uh
they haven't adjusted as david was
saying really to the time limit yeah
what is a good
tip to adjust to faster time controls
when you only have 15 minutes should you
play a game of bullet with someone in
your house yeah possibly yeah just move
quicker yeah scott you've got like
get amazon even just log on to chess 24
and play some bullet chess exactly just
i mean they had the time to play one
game maybe two games yeah she'll just
get in the rhythm um obviously you still
have to stop think and calculate a
little bit in blitz but there hasn't
been much calculation up to this point
it's just been maneuvering putting
pieces on squares choosing the pawn
structure
and those decisions you need to just
trust your instinct and uh i mean these
players are far better at blitz than me
but uh yeah either way they haven't
really found their rhythm and i'm
slightly worried about prague's time
usage so far
meanwhile slightly more time on the
clock lifting his rook up the board
interesting he's getting ready to swing
his other rook the rook that's asleep
across and line up both of his rooks on
the e file
interesting decision hinting at an
attack but also quite provocative this
gives prague a lot of choice and i think
that's quite a good thing in blitz if
you give your opponent a choice
then uh yeah they'll burn time on the
clock
under two minutes now as well i mean you
know for for 20 moves it's really
they've really especially prague has got
to pick up the pace here um because he's
gonna it's not even a critical moment
yet and if he gets to a critical moment
he's gonna need some time to work things
out he doesn't have that time
and he's still thinking he's just got to
move really i think he doesn't know what
to do i mean there's some uh tricks and
traps in the position because this rook
move as david mentioned you know the
brooks threatened to align with each
other but
what are you how are you going to break
out
and
pragananda
redeploying his bishop to a long
diagonal
yeah and giri he's finding the rhythm
look how he played his last move black's
move for sure that wasn't on his radar
it was slightly unexpected but he
reacted instantly and that's what you
need to do save the time for later the
tricks the traps the kind of decision
moment where this game um does reach its
climax that isn't that's still far far
away
so okay we did see a trade a black
bishop traded off for a white knight
white's pawn structure around his king
now slightly weird but the black knight
now having to retreat black is very
passive just defending everything but
long term black has the better pawn
structure
okay geary can he find something now
you have been quite
strict with anish's king today in the
last two games doing weird stuff with
his king yeah i mean the last game i
understood the game before that no idea
um i don't think geary will be able to
explain that king maneuver either in
game three of today but maybe a good
move here for example gaia would be to
tuck the white king onto the h2 square
just behind those pawns in the corner
just keep it nice and safe those paws
actually form a really nice shield
towards any attack i love this pawn
structure actually in blitz chess
especially because white's king never
comes under fire
but uh okay he steps the rook up one
square slightly mysterious simon do you
think he's going to go on the attack
swing that white rook across to the h
file and sacrifice yeah probably not
after this move i
mean black's bringing all his pieces
around his king just to make sure it's
super safe and prague is picking up the
pace but again just keep an eye on the
clock because they're they're both down
to about a minute there's a lot of
pieces on the board and it's it's
heating up but there hasn't been any
real tactics as of yet do you keep the
bishops on the board now or not i mean
uh i don't know what would you guys do
here difficult if the light squared
bishops come off white's attacking
chances really disappear right yeah but
then again if you allow the bishops to
stay on black's bishop might become a
strong piece
yeah well you have to take a decision i
personally in light of the clock
situation would probably just keep my
light square bishop on the board but uh
yeah decision time
i have a feeling gary's going to protect
his bishop with a pawn yeah there we go
that's a very girly type of move he's
maintaining the tension he doesn't want
to commit if we do see a trade of
bishops now white's pawn will recapture
and he gains an extra kind of influence
in the center
yeah what's the geary type of move like
just nice and solid and like keeping
things up
yeah slowly improving
makes sense yeah
under a minute now as well for prague so
it's not clear what black does actually
black has a whole bunch of moves you
could try but there are downsides to all
of them
also look at black's a pawn on the side
of the board the black queen the black
rook are tied down to that pawn
there are targets maybe for white's army
prague though he's frozen he spent half
his time on this one move
he needs to decide
if the worst comes yeah worst case worst
move your bishop
trade off some rooks
good move just cost him a long time and
geary under one minute as well yup it's
really going to heat up now i mean
they're they got to pick up the pace uh
something's going to happen very shortly
as in there's going to be some
explosions i think on the board uh do
you now take the bishop do you maneuver
i know you take 20 seconds to make a
decision when you've only got a minute
left
you know it's gotta gotta they've gotta
go quicker i can't believe how the speed
they're playing yeah and
i mean it's understandable they have
been playing rapid dress the whole week
but
yeah they just haven't adapted and okay
a trade of one set of rooks that's a
small gain long term for prague but
short term the black knights are very
passive
uh it's great to exchange pieces here i
think for prague just lessening the
pressure
but
okay kiri has an opportunity under 20
seconds
incredibly slow
and he's going trying to go on the
offensive here but
has and now prague is picking up the
pace so yeah
i was a little bit afraid about this uh
night move yes it looks great but uh the
pawn is under the pawn in the middle of
the board is undefended and i really
like giri's last move safety first
protects everything because you only got
15 seconds on the clock
yeah the white king is perfectly safe
that's the ideal formation around the
king having so many pawns around it
meanwhile okay the players are starting
to develop their pieces everything
protected in the black camp but giri's
going after some pawns maybe i like this
last move shifting the focus of white's
rook of white's attack
as the black richer swings across
black very nicely centralized right here
so it's uh
oh
is he getting ready to sacrifice for
that one good blitz move at least giri
is putting the fear of god into pregnant
trying to hint at some sacrifices
towards the black king but prague
he doesn't care he's cold as ice
attacking the white knight
and now the white knight getting booted
around
oh from geary this is a really risky
move the white queen defending her
knight
can the bishop come and i think it
blunders a piece yeah yeah
i mean bishop comes to to four because
that was called yeah this time of day
i'm not sure he finds the best move we
see the stockfish moves bishop to e4 and
stockfish says wins a piece double
attack simply winning a piece now and
annie leans back he simply blundered the
queen and knight were under attack at
the same time he lost his queen there he
was about to emerge a piece down and he
resigns wow prague with the black pieces
takes the lead in the blitz thai breaks
he